new questions about an effort to curb
climate change some companies and
individuals are trying to shrink their
carbon footprint by purchasing so-called
carbon offsets to essentially cancel out
their pollution this is often done by
planting trees and protecting forests
which help trap and store planet-warming
carbon dioxide but wildfires burning in
the west are threatening land set aside
for carbon offsets as senior national
and environmental correspondent ben
tracy reports that is making trees a
less reliable ally in the fight against
climate change
and so the fire came right through here
yeah the fire started to our west the
first thing you notice on a drive
through this normally lush green oregon
forest is that nearly all the trees are
dead
pretty much as far as your eye can see
it's burnt out yeah no it's it was a big
fire
last summer's bootleg fire was the third
largest wildfire in oregon history smoke
from the massive blaze turned the sky
gray as far away as new york city nearly
blocking out the sun
more than 400 thousand acres were lost
about 110 000 of that was on us on our
landscape it was very very tough it was
a tough thing to see honestly it made
you sad douglas reed is president of
green diamond timber company which owns
and logs this land
but they've also found another way to
make money on all of these trees
by not cutting them down
what us selling carbon offsets allows us
to do is change the way we manage this
forest to make it an older and more
mature forest companies like green
diamond let their trees grow longer and
larger allowing them to suck in more
planet-warming carbon dioxide in the
carbon offsets market that generates
credits they then sell to polluters
looking to offset their own carbon
emissions
in theory it's like balancing a scale
green diamond sold offsets to shell
philip 66 and microsoft
but when those trees went up in smoke
last year so did those offsets
and all that carbon that essentially was
being stored in the trees went up in the
atmosphere the fact that the fire
released a bunch of carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere yeah that did make it
more painful green diamond had promised
to keep the carbon represented by the
offsets locked away in this forest for
at least 100 years
we're not making that commitment idly
we're making the commitment with the
intent that we will fulfill it the
atmosphere doesn't care what your
intention is they're dead so they're
going to fall over they're going to
decompose danny cullen ward is policy
director for carbon plan a non-profit
that tracks and analyzes carbon offset
programs
so all of these trees that we're seeing
here that burned down yeah these were
all part of an offset program yep that's
right he says offsets are now a billion
dollar business with almost no oversight
he argues they often let polluters off
the hook their carbon emissions remain
in the atmosphere forever while the
offset in something like a tree is only
temporary
the problem comes in when people say
it's okay for me to pollute because i
bought one of these kinds of credits
cbs news analyzed corporate social
responsibility reports and found that
major polluters including big oil big
tobacco and big airlines are relying on
carbon offsets to help them meet their
climate goals
you will find airlines major industries
saying we've gone carbon neutral because
we've purchased these credits which i
think for many people gives a misleading
impression that these companies have
solved the problem when at best we are
getting started learning some things
that work and some things that really
don't work and many climate conscious
consumers are using them too a lot of
individuals who care about these things
are buying offsets for their plane trip
how do they know that any of that is
actually offsetting their pollution they
have no way of knowing there's no
regulations that exist in the usage of
these credits so a lot of this might
just be making people feel good
some of it certainly is
he also worries some timber companies
are now being paid to do what they would
have done anyway let their trees grow
the discussion looks a lot like give me
an offset credit or i'll cut down the
trees that's essentially the claim that
they're making it kind of sounds like
holding trees hostage it is directly
analogous to that yes
nearly half of all the carbon offsets in
the world are now stored in trees but
here in the american west which is
getting hotter and drier and more prone
to wildfires many are now saying that
forests like these are no longer a
reliable weapon in the fight against
climate change new research shows
wildfire risks could be at least four
times greater by the end of the century
and at least six large carbon offset
sites in forests in california oregon
and washington have burned in the past
seven years
trees and soil and other nature-based
solutions are inherently risky but we
don't have a choice at this point we
need to have nature as a climate
solution we're sober about the reality
of climate change elizabeth wilmot is
carbon program director at microsoft the
tech giant is pledging to be carbon
negative by 2030 and then remove the
equivalent of all its historical carbon
emissions by 2050. so the capacity of
this plant is four thousand tons it is
helping fund carbon removal projects
including this one we visited last year
in iceland this is going to make history
yes
which actually sucks carbon dioxide out
of the air and buries it underground
nature is nature but wilmot says it's
incredibly hard to find legitimate
offset and removal programs we first
started our carbon removal program we
got
200 project proposals
and many of those didn't actually
describe carbon removal microsoft
thoroughly vetted green diamond and paid
them to offset hundreds of thousands of
tons of its co2 emissions and then many
of those offsets
burned in the bootleg fire isn't the
very nature of an offset allowing a
company to continue to pollute it's not
actually
solving the problem we need to both
reduce and remove so make dramatic cuts
in our carbon emissions and also then
offset what we can't california runs one
of the largest offset programs in the
world it tries to manage the risk of
drought in wildfire by placing a portion
of each forest offset credits into a
reserve account like insurance when a
forest burns down those credits are
removed from the system to offset the
offset yeah danny cullenward says that
so-called buffer pool
isn't keeping up with the new normal of
climate change fueled wildfires
california's air resources board
disagrees with that characterization in
the span of about less than 10 years
we've essentially burned through the
insurance protections that were meant to
last 100
but i don't think it's right to throw
the baby out with the bathwater we got a
lot of work to do douglas reed
acknowledges the offsets market may need
higher standards but says trees are
worth the risk are there risks in trees
is it possible that they burn yes that's
possibility at this stage we can't
afford not to use all the tools that we
have for cbs saturday morning i'm ben
tracy in eastern oregon
there's no doubt his last statement is
true right we have to do everything we
can but we were all saying throughout
the piece oh yeah oh wait yeah we've got
to find solutions yeah the solutions are
going to be painful but until we start
making them we aren't going to see any
kind of reversal on on some of the
issues that we're facing and that is
the pull control what a great looking
yeah i mean what a great look at this
overall yeah yeah a billion dollar
business with no oversight we have to
offset
the offset so that reminds me of that
fusion piece oh
yeah
great job ben tracy and producers